hi in this video I'm going to
demonstrate the optical sectioning
property of our confocal microscope or
any good kind of aperture microscope so
in the left-hand side you can see there
is an animal cell and in the right hand
side in the inset you can see the cross
sectional view so optical sectioning is
a property of confocal microscope which
actually doesn't section the specimen
but it's sectioning the specimen
optically that means it's imaging
separate focal plane at several time
points so if you look at the image on
the left side you can see due to the
motorized stage of the microscope the
flop focal plane is changing every time
point and on the insect you can see that
cellular details is also changing now
the cellular details is significant
amount when it goes into the deeper
focal plane the amount of the cellular
details is decreasing and the microscope
would take the image from the deeper
focal plane to the topmost focal plane
and reconstruct the whole image into a
maximum intensity projection and we
would see a maximum intensity projection
map of that particular cell and this is
how the confocal microscope optical
sectioning works I hope this video was
useful for you if you like my video
let's give it a quick thumbs up and
don't forget to subscribe thank you